what I like to do right now is do an
impression of every comedian who
couldn't make it tonight
I'm going to give you a stopwatch so
every 10 seconds tell me to change
you're ready go why do people have
birthday parties they got the balloons
you have cake it's one year closer to
death what is that change oh thank you
very much
change yeah yeah
yeah you gotta change what is this what
kind of a party is this I saw Chris
Christie backstage putting a jalapeno
down a stripper's g-string that's not
right change
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
what was the best part of living in the
white house I think it was uh going
downstairs with Michelle you know
blocking out all the security cameras
and I have an intercourse George
Washington's face that's what we did
Michelle have a seat Michelle I'm gonna
start the motor no no no no have a
and start the more no no here we go
no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no I want to lay
out my intentions now right now my
professional life is at annoying so I
know they'll sketch I've seen it same
with Brian Williams I can slow jam
You're Never Gonna Make it Joe you're
never gonna make it this was the most
beautiful piece of cake I invented water
Howard that's really important finally
getting the credit that was due to me
stop getting around here come on number
one the one part number two what the guy
said number three you know the drill oh
Paula sleeping you can't so we just like
take us some kind of you know flat
accent and just try these terrorists
these guys are uh
these guys are bad every person matters
north and south east and west
we can't have any Impressions you do
have you ever edited them up no it's
really [__] remarkable I do micro
Impressions now just to amuse myself
like you could just run through them
well they're just real quick like this
is uh Sean Connery being asked whether
he would like to vacation in Spain okay
yeah
so that's those are a new way to do them
right wow yeah I like that yeah just
just quick hit yeah people just do too
much material Michael Kane is a toddler
a Coco
I can't say anymore because I'm only two
bloody as hell so I yeah just get two of
them but I would I wish you would just
do like a a whole show of just being
Paul McCartney I could [__] hack I
could do it the thing the thing I love
about Paul is that the the Persona of
human is so humble how did you how did
you really write Eleanor Rigby well I
sat down for a plunk
and you know she's keeping her face in
the job of the door you know and John
said it's a goodie it's a good one right
there I love Impressions especially on
the radio when I do Paul McCartney on
Mars this is one of my micro Impressions
okay we didn't know it would be so red
that's a more another micro I do
um let's see I do well I did this on The
Today Show yesterday this is Tom Brokaw
asking where the library is in Spanish
so they're just ridiculous right has
there ever been anyone that you couldn't
do like you said I'm gonna study this
guy I'm gonna get him down I'm gonna do
it was there ever that frustration that
I just can't get it I mean I think
George Bush Senior took me a year really
because you got to figure out I would
just kind of talking like this I'm
George Bush you know and then I was at
the you know 17th floor with Al Franken
one night and I just started going it
hit me that that thing out there
in that whole area and that was it and
once you get it once you get the hook
you can do it then you're in not gonna
do that education do you know what's
great about it once you do the
impression then 10 million people come
out of the woodworking can do it which
is the best way to learn an impression
we're gonna go for a walk you and me
without cuffs you [__] me
I'm gonna put one in your back and then
now they oh
wow A E I O U it's easier to do Al now
come on where are we going with this
what happens if I don't stop smoking the
cigarettes listen you're trying to get
something out of me is that what you're
doing man that's what I'm doing right
now yeah thanks Alex
they want to get [__] Travolta over
me we have [__] bones doing these
guys you're [__] John Gotti who the
[__] you I'mma want to play junk out of
here you're very good Alex
is the reason that Bruce Springsteen did
an entire week of uh Jimmy Fallon shows
with you is that because he saw you
doing Bruce Springsteen and he loved it
so much what happened was we did the uh
Emmy Awards right I hosted the Emmy
Awards in the opening of the Emmys we
did like a Glee version of Born to Run
right so we asked his manager if we can
do it and he goes whatever whatever
Jimmy wants to do yeah I think he's
funny he wants to do something there
they don't do it and then uh he liked it
and then his manager called up and said
look he has to do a press on this box
head uh he's not doing any shows but he
knows you're a fan so he'd love to do
your show wow so I go what do you want
to do a bit
so we just did Neil Young path on the
ground and so this great writer Mike
disenzo is like what if you did um Whip
My Hair Willow Smith you know uh that
you know I whip my hair back and forth I
whip my head but as Neil Young and I go
oh my God great a great idea what if you
think if we could add Bruce Springsteen
to do like a duet he's like I don't
think he'll do it but let's try so we we
put our phone out and we were just we
were just playing the guitar and just
strumming around like we're just like
just like noodling around trying to
figure out and whip my hair back and
forth
whip my hair back and forth whip it real
good
you know and I'm like then we gotta have
Bruce come in tonight so he's like whip
my hair back and forth
[Music]
and I wanted to do like a Bruce
breakdown was like whoa
my
hair oh
gotta whip your air whoa
like some something that you'd see it
you know throughout the garden yeah you
know firemen going nuts yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was beautiful so we sent it to
Bruce and he goes he loved it when you
were doing impressions for Lauren like
do you remember what you auditioned I
did a celebrity walkathon I'll have that
go why don't we just take a bus
I did Alan Rickman and Die Hard
thank you it was Nathan Lane for the
hamburger Society something peculiar
something for everyone eat a hamburger
tonight and that was it it was the
dumbest joke in the world Vin Diesel the
diesel I don't know why how do you do
Vin Diesel at an audition Vin Diesel
there's this thing in this voice well it
sounds like he's got space Hood
wait a minute you did Robin Williams for
those who are nested this is a frisbee
Oh look The spaceship's Coming forward
Al Pacino trying to do his own line of
pants pants pants shopton was very much
like a preacher so it gets real gusted
Michael J fox hey Sarge You Gotta Give
me a little time on this oh Christ
Mallory I did Donahue in Spanish Donahue
what is Donahue in Spanish well Saya
simpatico cone makeup
oh okay nobody here has done good your
tingle belly directs the Eunice and I
mean come on
your voice is a very deep nice speaking
voice I think that has a lot to do with
doing impressions and sort of being
relaxed on camera and everything if
you've got a really kind of easy
speaking voice what was it like the
first time you went out on stage uh
Saturday Night Live what character are
you doing do you remember I remember it
was in a Hurricane Katrina sketch where
I was Al Pacino
we'll put the doors wherever we want
I love your Al Pacino oh thank you my my
favorite impression of yours Al Pacino
and Alan Aldo the dinosaur comes out and
attacks me I said he's great that is
just terrific if I said to you now do
some Alan Alda is that difficult you
have to work into it or do you yeah I
have to kind of work into it those are
always how do you work into something
like that I watch him from crimes and
misdemeanors right you just watch them
over and over again and I'm doing the
thing about you know if it bends you
know that thing you know if it bends
it's funny if it breaks it's not funny
there's a whole scene in crimes and
misdemeanors but it was nice because I
talked to like Daryl Hammond when I
started the show and uh
um Dana Carvey you know when he came to
the show and asked them about
Impressions and it made me feel better
that they were kind of the same way
they're like oh yeah it's hard to kind
of just go right into it
Eddie Murphy now he's just real you know
he's cool and he's just like this and
he's not like he's not like this you
know what I mean to be turning up and be
doing all that with your fingers and the
voices this is Eddie Murphy when Eddie
Murphy doing the character and I don't
need to deal with that stop it don't do
it go after Kramer uh yeah I got an idea
where you're smoking an extra long
cigarette
you know it's like a couch here yet like
you want to sleep right you want to lay
down right but you know what you're not
supposed to lay down right what am I
doing I'm sitting here with two of
[__] waiting for a guy who can suck
his own dick how you doing you think
dinosaurs existed yes how you know you
ain't never seen one jealousy from going
to Neighbors in the Bible it's in the
Bible now watch let's watch some
pornography hey do you have a nickname
for your schlong I call it Sauron from
Lord of the Rings yeah for those of you
at homo don't know you're watching a
thing called a television
uh I I mean do you like cars it's a
little bit of a list there it's just you
know but that's a real person
I would stop Howard
monster keep Chris Rock's name out your
[__] mouth okay coward Howard look
it's like this you know I know like I'm
200 I'm 200 pounds I'm six foot two
Chris Rock is 5 foot 10 45 pounds like
it should have brought her never
happened
not too many guys can do uh this list
what do you got over there Bill Clinton
Al Gore Giuliani Jay Leno you do do a
good Leno here's something interesting
no no no I'm not making this up Lance
and gentlemen you know you know Sears
Roebuck that's not silly McDonald's ham
I guess you know about this yeah we know
but what is this about gonna start
selling McDonald's ham because oh go to
McDonald's oh
I can see it now take a growing a pound
of fries wanna
one time I just want to go down your
whole list and have you rapid fire do a
mall that would be like one big orgasm
for me I could peel off about 24. could
you please peel off I swear I will come
on
Porky Pig oh and the V Sylvester hey
when we eat what are you doing with that
Debra b e rope and that if you get a
razor uh we'll be eating some good man
Barney five during our lifetime we
travel many roads there are big roads
and little roads rocky roads and smooth
roads dirt highways and improved roads
that's the greatest yeah Barney's the
favorite of all time really that I ever
did it's so good yeah and he was such a
cold character and you know I was
starting it was a popular thing down
south if you could do Barney and of
course I didn't know what to do I'd be
up on stage I'd be so scared so I'd
start doing blue stuff you know as
Barney just ridiculous stuff Andy Andy
oh hey I hope he's out in the backyard
bopping his baloney
see my honey big and shiny makes you
giggle to see it wiggle
how's that for you brother beautiful I
love it all right Sean Connery uh that's
a good one so I knew I was gonna make a
mark in Show Business I just didn't
think it would be your mother's a [__]
I'm Brad Pitt I'm bronze I'm chiseled
and I'm firm and I was like duh winning
hey flew schnitzel movie making predator
and then be a long pause and be like
Jesse Ventura
Carl Weathers they should need some all
of a sudden you start looking like
Denzel you talk like Denzel you look
like him and you start thinking like
Denzel Howard that's what it's about
right huh I can't believe this this is
like crazy being here like Family Feud
right Sandy Steve Harvey what you're
doing is it joyous beautiful game show
where families get your Feud
I love your stand up I loved you on the
Living Color that's when I first kind of
like got keyed into you and then you
know you kind of like just kept it going
and then and then with Ray I mean did
you glue your eyes shut or something for
that movie yeah I glued my eyes shut up
on Ray Charles I would be blind for 12
hours which is weird because you know
you at first you get a little oh wow you
get a little like you get a little
claustrophobic but when I met Ray
Charles
you want to talk about a boss really so
far I walk into his studio and he's
walking down the hallway and I say uh Mr
Charles you know I really want to do the
best thing I can you know to to to to do
is that let me tell you something if you
could play the blues baby you could do
anything man hey let's play the blues so
you sat down on on Dual pianos and
started playing was he critical of you
or did he go watch it so we're playing
right we're playing and we're doing the
blues one and then he goes into
Thelonious Monk and so I'm trying to
mirror him on that and then I hit a
wrong note and he said what now why the
hell would you do that I said what
because to his his ears are so sensitive
yes
what the hell what the [__] are you
doing I said I'm sorry I didn't I didn't
know he said let me tell you something
at the notes are right underneath your
fingers baby all you got to do that's
life life is hitting all right no they
hit the right note
are you planning to buy a house in India
I know you've become India yeah Robin
it's not true you can't keep bringing up
these mad rumors what is wrong with you
yeah
I have these snatched lips on my [__]
oh get over yourself you're not even
pretty I I I I I
don't know
[Music]
come on come on
yeah you're gonna see uh girl you're
gonna think the [__] is piss but it ain't
piss it's clear come and
get it
look at what you've done wow we've said
it we've said it all
let's just make one more call let's go
ahead and this is uh this is Ozzy
Osbourne you're on the air
yes
somebody knocked me out after last night
show
I don't know
it's not a great impression that
impression sucks
show them how it's done
this is a story all about how my life
got flipped turned upside down
I'd like to take a minute just sit right
there
okay how I became the prince of a town
called Bel Air
[Music]